before he ever picked up a lightsaber
Iman es fanii was firing away Precision
strikes with a very different Implement
from showing up in random commercials to
throwing down at slam poetry shows
here's what you didn't know about the
Ahsoka Star Iman as fandi grew up in the
small Texas border city of Laro which is
known for having the highest proportion
of Hispanic Americans of any city in the
United States outside of Puerto Rico
this lack of ethnic diversity proved
challenging for as fanii whose mother
hails from Ecuador and whose father
comes from Iran as he explains at the
daily Texon in 2022 I was around zero
Persian people my whole life mostly
around Mexican and Caucasian people
Texas Caucasian people can be really
rough especially the years I was growing
up very country homophobic islamophobic
and brutal and in an interview with
flaun as fondy record I grew up with the
repercussions of 9/11 all throughout my
childhood when I was younger it wasn't
as noticeable but by the time I was in
high school I could better see the mic C
aggressions that my being half Persian
or my father being from Iran would
incite as FY would later utilize us
racism to help fuel his career as F's
parents have been business owners in the
radio for most of their son's life he
spent a considerable amount of his
childhood in the family shop and even
hoped to one day following their
footsteps so he got an associates degree
from his hometown School of Laredo
college and then he later graduated from
the University of Texas with a
bachelor's in economics with the
expectation of running a business
similar to his parents sharp but then he
changed his focus when he discovered a
passion for film and art as he recall to
shout out La in 2021 I wasn't taught how
to express myself didn't have any
examples of how to become an artist I'm
grateful though for it's the start
contrast of my upbringing to my current
lifestyle it's humbling and empowering
to remind myself that I started from
nothing and wasn't handed things on a
silver platter there was yet another
completely different life trajectory
that as fondi almost ended up on as he
was once considered to be a bit of a
tennis prodigy he took up the sport at
the age of 133 and spent his high school
senior year practicing at the John newom
Tennis Academy in new brunfels Texas he
was even at one point ranked in the top
five in the country while playing
Collegiate tennnis at Laredo College as
fanii kept playing for years and he
eventually became a mentor and an
instructor for tennis prospects of all
ages as recently as 2020 his athletic
background came in handy in 2021 when he
landed a small role in the movie King
Richard which tells the story of Richard
Williams father of the legendary Venus
and Serena this guy Richard Williams
keeps Callin like the 10th time in a row
as fondy remains obsessed with the game
as he regularly shares highlights of his
practices and matches on Instagram with
a sports background and a fine education
it wasn't exactly the obvious choice for
Iman as fi to dive head first into
acting but he found his own Direction in
life by taking a unique route as he
explained to Voyage La in 2019 I have
been conducting impromptu interviews at
coffee shops around Austin with anyone
who was interested in starting a up a
conversation it was my way to research
different life paths without having to
experience them myself as fondi
eventually took his project to a local
acting Workshop as he recall I did in
fact meet people who had drastically
changed their life past but another
interesting thing also happened I ended
up volunteering to work through a couple
of scenes as fandy impressed the casting
directors who are operating the workshop
and was encouraged to find a manager and
pursue an acting career so he started
attending workshops around Austin and
landed some substantial roles in student
projects and short films before fully
committing by making the move to Los
Angeles in
2018 like plenty of other actors e minus
fondy got his start on scream with some
TV commercial gigs impressively enough
he landed his first national televised
campaign shortly after attending his
first acting Workshop since then as
fondy has managed to book a veritable
slew of ads for the likes of such
companies as Amazon Bose and H&R BL one
spot for Al Bean features him sleeping
on top of a ladder of hammocks as he
wishes his camping mates a good morning
he also appeared in Coca-Cola's food
Feud Campaign which features people
making their cases for various meals as
the optimal thing to eat while watching
football as FY plays a guy who stumps
for a certain type of iconic sandwich
dude subs for many actors it's a Natural
Evolution to one day sit in the
director's chair and run the show behind
the camera e minus fondi has actually
already made this transition as he's an
award-winning director of short films
his first and most notable stint as a
director came as a passion project
alongside his childhood friend Isaac
Gaza Gaza approached as fandi about
helping him produce an absurdest comedy
short titled Papito with Gaza writing
and starring he invited esfandi to be
the director so esfandi taught himself
how to direct by devouring a crash
course of YouTube videos and then he
took the helm for the 3-day shoot to
their surprise Papito went on to be
selected as a winner of The latine X
short film festival in 2019 and had also
earned a nationwide distribution deal on
HBO platforms as fandy followed up that
Triumph by directing another short film
called 120 which premiered at the can
shot film Corner since then though he's
pretty much abandoned the director's
chair as he's chosen instead to focus on
his acting and other creative Pursuits
the co 19 pandemic left a huge
percentage of the world's population to
their own devices while they were logged
up in quarantine e minus fi decided to
use this isolation to his Advantage by
pursuing artistic Outlets Beyond film
making this including discovering a love
for slam poetry slum poetry involves
performing an original piece in front of
an audience that's encouraged to
participate with finger snaps or words
of affirmation this eccentric genre of
live entertainment is fitting for
someone like us fondi as it's often
treated as a highly emotional monologue
that relies on the performer's
individual style he's continued to
practice this unique art form including
in March 2023 when he shared an
Instagram real of himself performing a
rendition of his poem I'm tired you
good hey you good it was a natural
progression for Asi to adapt his
passions for poetry and Performing into
a music career under the stage name of
dragon wolf he spent much of his time in
quarantine learning everything he could
about producing his own songs as he
explained to Theo morning times in 2023
I learned so much about music over the
course of the year I realized I want to
do this all the way in forever as FY
released his first dragon wolf EP in
September 2020 though he eventually
decided to make it no longer available
as he explained I took a more
professional approach to learning it all
carving out my style and figuring out
what it is I wanted to do with the music
as FY then released a new single you're
perfect in every way and he since
followed that up with three albums a
dragon wolf summer Lai anver and the
Sagrada Familia as FY has looked back on
his musical journey by reflecting it was
a lot of self and inner work and
Discovery and expression it broke
through a bunch of barriers of fear
anxiety and insecurities and eradicated
all that working on something as big as
a SOA is sure to help as FY land himself
some some higher profile projects in the
near future but he's actually already
built himself a pretty solid filmography
his onscreen credits date back to 2017
when he starred in an assortment of
short films with names like death by
Script and mother of the golds by 2018
as fondy hooked up with fellow Star Wars
veteran Robert Rodriguez the actor star
in Rodriguez's low budget flick red 11
which had its well premere at the 2019
South by Southwest Film Festival as FY
then made his Silver Screen debut in
2021 King Richard before taking a more
substantial role in 2022 the inspection
it was a part that really hit close to
home as he played a Muslim American man
recruited into the Marines during the
height of post 911
islamophobia been convicted of aelon are
you commun as impressive as as F's rise
through the Hollywood ranks has been he
still faced some adversity particularly
when it comes to the types of roles he
gets offers for since moving to Los
Angeles in 2018 he's gone out on Plenty
of auditions unfortunately the parts
that he generally gets the most calls
for are stereotypical and frequently
racist characters that seem to be stuck
on his Iranian Heritage as he noted to
the Daily Texon in 2022 I'm not going to
audition for something that's offensive
I'm not perfect for a role because I'm
Brown I'm not perfect for that because I
can play this side character I'm perfect
for real characters because I'm a real
person as fi also pointed out that his
role in the inspection was a good
example of the sort of character he
prefers to play in that film he was able
to represent both his Persian background
and his Ecuadorian Heritage meanwhile
the part also allows him to explore and
confront much of the racism that he's
enjoed throughout his life it's
difficult for his fandi to ignore how
meteorically his career has taken off by
playing a fan favorite character in one
of the world's biggest franchises but
that doesn't mean that this development
is a total surprise to him he credits
the power of manifestation as a major
reason for his success it's also a huge
influence on his music as the power of
belief has helped him turn his dreams
into reality as he explained to the Laro
morning time s I'm wrapping from a place
in the future that I'm adopting the
feeling of and calling that into my life
I dropped a dragon wolf summer and this
very Flex rap and extravagant I'm
flexing and that's when I booked Star
Wars it doesn't get more obvious that
these Concepts work as fondy also noted
I know how the universe works on a
spiritual level and I know I can get a
hold of it on a physical tangible level
if anything at the end of this whole
thing I'll be living proof and these
songs will be my
retrospect it's no secret that the Star
Wars fandom can be quite finicky when
new characters or new versions of
established characters enter the
franchise all you have to do is go
anywhere on the internet where Star Wars
fans gather to understand how difficult
they can be to please but plenty of
viewers seem to be embracing as fandy as
a live action choice for beloved Rebels
hero Ezra Bridger so it might be a
little surprising to learn that as fandi
had some serious competition during the
casting process many actors expressed
interest in the role for a sooker and
one of the leading names rumored for the
part was the lead of the live action
Aladdin Mino masud mud even quoted Ezra
on an Instagram post back in 2021 which
fueled speculation that he was close to
nabbing the part masud inevitably had to
address the casting decision when it was
announced as fandy won the part in a
sined tweet he wrote glad the rumors
will stop now never really had a fair
shot at it unfortunately just wasn't
meant for me I guess can't deny the dude
looks exactly like Ezra it all seems to
have worked out for the best versus
fondy is flourishing in the role leading
to rumors that Ezra Bridger may get his
very own Disney plus Series in the near
future
[Music]
yeah